[Music]
hi
my name is sophie byers thank you for
watching my video um i'm super honored
to be a part of this conference
i definitely wish that we could all be
in person but in the meantime
welcome to my kitchen i am excited to
talk to you a little bit about my
process in creating data visualizations
and data driven stories at the aclu
so just a little bit about me i'm a data
journalist at the aclu where i analyze
data for our lawyers legal arguments
and visualize and report on our data for
external advocacy purposes
i'm only a few years into being a part
of the art community
so i'm really excited to be here so to
start
uh what is data science and data
journalism more broadly at the aclu
some of you might know and remember uh
brooke mata buanwu who
who spoke at the 2019 rstudio conference
about her data work in helping reunify
children that were separated from their
families while seeking refuge in our
country
she happens to be my awesome manager and
colleague and i felt she recently summed
up our work in just one slack
that reads the lawyer called our
analysis both deeply disturbing
and extremely helpful which might just
be the slogan for our team
this leads me to an important word to
define
turbulus which is commonly used on our
team as a way of expressing excitement
over being able to prove
usually terrible news with quantitative
evidence
our analysis of the data that we receive
often uncovers disparities that hold up
in court
and help our lawyers win their legal
arguments
but in all seriousness what this often
means is the data that we are privileged
to analyze
represent real human beings who who are
being harmed in one way or another
i'll briefly share with you a few
examples of what this might mean
for example each row in this data was a
person that was filed for eviction
we found in this case that filings for
eviction impacted black women
at alarmingly disproportionate rates
another example is this recent report
that we put out where
where we found that black people despite
using marijuana at the same rates as
white people
are still being disproportionately
arrested for possession of marijuana
we also found that people of color were
more likely to have their driver's
licenses suspended due to unpaid and
often
unaffordable fines and fees and we were
able to visualize the story of
of two black women who whose lives were
turned upside down
without the ability to use their cars
all in all i've been really lucky to be
a part of these and other data
journalistic projects during my time at
the aclu
um so i wanted to talk to you a little
bit about the process that i often go
through
and the key steps i take in creating my
data visualizations
this will include the feedback that i
sometimes receive
what i've done or not done with that
feedback and other considerations that i
think are important
in getting to a final result
so some of you might be thinking that
it's just uh this easy
you go from data analysis to
visualization
uh you're good you have a great vis and
you can go on and just enjoy your
weekend
maybe even i thought that at one point
uh based on this slack evidence when i
was analyzing data a few months into the
pandemic
and came to the conclusion that actually
letting incarcerated people out of jails
had no effect on crime levels nearby
spoiler this is not the process but but
it was the finding
the actual process in my experience um
can be really messy
um and definitely not linear but i'll
share with you the key elements and
considerations to take that i believe
have set me up for a success for
projects like this
first you'll get some data a lot of the
time
for us here that means that a lawyer
will have some kind of data that they've
obtained through the discovery process
or through a foia request and a lot of
times we'll just use
publicly available data
next you'll use r to read it and explore
that data
during the exploration process i use the
tidy verse quite a bit
but also the janitor package is one of
my favorites to make easy tables
and always ggplot2 to find quick trends
and actually start visualizing my
findings
so this is important by now you'll
you'll want to start thinking about what
are your main points that you found in
your exploration that you want to
visualize and make clear
ask yourself does my visualization
support and highlight my main point
you'll also want to carefully consider
your audience um
is your audience made of purely
academics are they advocates
are they people who know a lot about
your topic already or maybe they know
nothing at all it's always um
also good to ask for feedback on your
visualizations from various people
you'll want to be specific about the
main points that you're trying to
visualize
before receiving feedback about whether
those main points are coming
through clearly are not to those people
and then you might find that once you
receive feedback you'll
start iterating on your database which
means you'll likely need to go kind of
back and forth and check a lot of these
boxes again
the process could end up looking a lot
like this
now to show you how i've gone about
using this process in practice
i'll go through these steps once more
with a real life example
for the purposes of the example that
i'll use i'll need to start with a
little bit of background on this recent
project that our team worked on
sometime into the very beginning of the
coven 19 pandemic
it became really clear that people in
jails and people
that were incarcerated in america which
by the way has the highest incarceration
rate in the world
in particular would be at risk
incarcerated people are subject to
extreme overcrowding
and jails often lack the resources and
facilities
that allow for hand washing and other
hygienic practices
that are necessary to slow the spread of
coven 19.
so it was really clear that in order to
save lives action had to be taken
and it had to be taken quickly our team
partnered with academic researchers
to build a model that accounted for the
dynamics of the jail system
and estimated the additional illnesses
and loss of life that we'd expect if
if none of these preventative measures
were taken
we recommended reducing arrests such
that people were only being arrested for
the most serious incidents and promptly
releasing people who were pre-trial
or charged for low-level crimes or were
particularly vulnerable to the disease
and pose no risk of immediate threat to
others
all in all the team estimated that
taking these precautions could save a
hundred thousand human lives
both inside the jails and in their
surrounding communities
many communities did begin prioritizing
the lives of incarcerated people and the
people who worked within jails
and some localities reduced low level
arrests or set bond at zero
or released a subset of incarcerated
people but there was some backlash
some people were worried that taking
these actions would result in a huge
spike in crime in the surrounding
communities
despite research uh showing that in new
york city for instance
people released from jails due to coven
were rearrested at lower rates than even
expected
to quell these concerns further our team
analyzed trends in reported crimes
during the initial three months of the
pandemic
in 29 of the largest u.s cities where
data was available
and released this report with our
findings
for the purposes of this project our
goal is to find whether there was any
relationship
between the change in county jail
populations and the reported crime rate
in the closest metropolitan area
so back to the process uh starting with
with the data step
we needed two categories of data one for
county jail populations and one that
showed the number of crimes reported in
the nearest city
these were ultimately the 29 locations
for which i could find
quality reported crime data for for the
time periods necessary that were either
aggregated daily weekly or monthly for
all of 2019
through may 2020 that we could also find
jail population and from
information for so we needed both um we
collected this data a bit in piecemeal
mainly through
googling for specific county sheriff's
offices or finding public open data sets
we ended up downloading countless csvs
and excel files and even pdfs kind of
continuously
whenever we noticed a bit a new bit of
data had dropped
hence the circular arrow around the data
step
we also used the veer institute's data
that tracked the number of people in
each county jail over time
and use we ended up using the specific
dates of february 29th and april 30th
to calculate the the percent change in
jail population
because most jails took action early on
in the pandemic we looked at the crime
rates um
during the time period of march through
may 2019 and compared those to the same
time period in 2020
and then to sort of standardize the way
that we analyzed crime and also because
many of these cities crime data sets
only included these types of crimes
we focused on part one crimes which are
defined by the uniform crime reporting
program
and they encompass the most frequently
reported violent and property crimes
you'll see that data exploration here
was was super messy for me
this is an example of what i saw using
this function
for my very favorite janitor package on
the crime description column in just one
city
during my exploration i created this
plot in r um
which which showed the relationship
between
the magnitude of the change in jail
population
and the magnitude of the change in in
crime during that same time frame
now it could be really tempting to draw
a regression line
and to try and focus on some type of
significant correlation
that just isn't there um i received
feedback from my colleagues that this
graph focused a little bit too much on
sort of the outliers
which were one location that increased
their jail population
and one location where there was more
reported crime than in the previous year
it was then i realized that one of the
most important main points that i could
make was actually the lack of
relationship between x and y
so after lots of data cleaning and
trying out uh more charts and receiving
more feedback
these were the three main points that i
wanted to make clear in my report
and um and visualize to my audience that
one
crime was not on the rise compared to
the same time period the year prior
um crime rates were instead right within
normal range
or even lower second most of the locales
that we found data for
did decrease their jail populations
during this time period
and like i said before just one location
actually increase its population
lastly and importantly we found no
relationship between the county jail
population
and its increase or decrease and the
number of crimes that were reported
so once i decided on these main points
it was time to come up
with a few mock-ups of graphs that i
thought would clearly express these
of course though this is not always easy
especially when you realize that you
need to take your audience into
consideration
so unfortunately this is an example of a
time where i thought
i nailed it i had come to the perfect
solution
but i hadn't yet considered our audience
so this is a graph that shows the 29
locations in order of the percent change
in jail population
the gray bar indicates the range of
monthly crimes between
january 2018 and february 2020 and the
three dots indicate the number of
monthly crimes reported in march
april and may of 2020 you'll see that a
lot of the time
the three dots are to the left of the
gray bar but never are they
to the right of the gray bar which
indicates that reported crime during
these first few months of the pandemic
were within normal or expected range or
lower
i will give credit to lucia our chief
analytics officer for scribbling down
this idea in slack of course
but will give credit to myself for what
i felt was
kind of incredible execution uh the team
of data scientists
of course loved it i thought it was
basically done
but let's remember your audience is key
so the next day i received the following
feedback from several non-analytics
folks
it honestly was a little bit like
reading my own bad reviews
um but it's important not to look at
constructive feedback that way
these colleagues were speaking up about
some major issues with this graph
you might agree i agree now they were
right
i see feedback that's qualified with
things like i'm not a numbers person
a lot people sometimes blame themselves
for not knowing how to interpret a data
vis
but it's actually really our job to make
sure that the viz works for them
and works for our audience so this
crimes and decarceration report was not
just for data scientists
it was for a far more general audience
and this chart was clearly not working
so sometimes this means going back to
the drawing board and doing a little bit
more data exploration
always with the janitor and gg plot
packages for me
and trying out sort of new ways of
visualizing your main points
while thinking about your audience these
charts were
hashtag innoventive but they simply
weren't working
some of the most valuable feedback
conversations i had were not over slack
so i have no hard evidence
but in the times that you're asking for
feedback from someone
it's really important to ask the why
behind something isn't working for them
um sometimes the the why might be
sort of surprising um or maybe it'll
it'll make you actually realize that
what you need to do is add better
annotating
rather than just like scrapping the
whole thing and starting over
and in the spirit of reiterating that
this process was one messy adventure
before showing you uh the final
visualizations we ended up with
at the end of the day i really feel like
this quote just kind of drives it all
home
so these were the final graphics that we
published on our site
both were created in r and touched up in
illustrator um
both i feel do a good job of expressing
our three main points
and are not just for not just
interpretable for for quote
numbers people i know these are probably
a little bit hard to see
so i'll share a link to my report in my
presentation
as well as where you can find the r code
for the analysis and viz
and one last wrench i'll throw at you
because it was thrown at me was that it
turns out police data is often dynamic
meaning that sometimes crimes that
occurred actually maybe a month ago
could have been reported today
um i cannot stress enough how much of a
lifesaver reusable code in r was
throughout this process
given the amount of extremely last
minute data dumps and sort of changing
out
you know csv files here and there we
want it to be precise
and it's thanks to r that remaking these
graphs time and time again was such a
small deal
so hopefully through this process i've
been able to convince you that
data vis is and and should often be
non-linear
mentors in my life have taught me that
being good at making effective
visualizations
is not about getting from point a to
point b the quickest
it's actually about carefully
considering each of these points
that makes you an effective communicator
to your audience
lastly feel free to reach out to me if
you have any questions or just want to
nerd out about data vis
and thank you
[Music]
you